The final thing that I wanted to mention in this overview of
software architecture, is evaluation. It doesn't do you that much good
to develop this fancy architecture, if it's not the right one. Okay? So,
we need some process by which we can judge the correctness, completeness,
consistency. And other quality aspects of the architecture we've produced.
Because of its, the importance of software architecture on the ultimate
product being developed, it's key to get it right.
Because if we make a mistake, it's very costly to make a change. So,
some approaches have been developed for dealing with architectural evaluation.
One of those, is architecture review boards. That is, for large systems which
are developed by multiple teams. Or, maybe systems of systems. Making a change
can have impacts on various unexpected places in, in the ultimate system. And
so it's good to have the stakeholders, particularly development stakeholders,
sit down and evaluate the impact of those changes. Some organizations have,
formalized this into a periodic meetings. That review suggested for
architecture, suggestions for architectural changes. Also some, so,
some evaluation techniques have been developed. Software architecture assessment
method, or SAAM. I'm going to show you a slide on this. It's, is a relatively
informal one. More formal one developed at the Software Engineering Institute,
is the Architecture Tradeoff Analysis Method, or ATAM.